différents il ya des changements j'ai
tout de suite d'ailleurs bas vous aimez
d'un point de vue purement commandes
attends attends nous dit ça comme ça on
ok on va me dire ok on comprend donc
pertinent dans ce qu'on va faire dans
fait différents trucs ici dans le studio
de l'objectivité versus la subjectivité
l'objectivité à versus la subjectivité
connaît l'histoire de la chanson et ça
comment je pourrais dire sans m'en
je voulais vous parler de sujets qui me
bien ce que je dis ça une résonance un
notre job est dans mon job ici c'est de
d'un côté tu es objectifs sur les specs
c'est super intéressant de dire ah oui
rendre compte à un moment tu dit attends
je vais continuer à faire évoluer un peu
c'est un poc est très très très complexe
sens pour vous sinon vous allez vous
garder totalement cette objectivité et
oui il faut revenir là et on revient on
alors regardez on va se remettre ici up
oui mais quelque part sur scène c'est un
semble être extrêmement important c'est
l'histoire c'est encore des choses qui
pourquoi parce que il faut être un peu
d'un côté tu es subjectif par rapport à
client l'idée c'est pas de mettre en
vont arriver et quand ça sera fini ça
seriez pas là en train d'écouter même
repose on questionne on réfléchit
il est évident que je vais moi quand je
la question de l'objectivité de la
factuel il faut venir un peu à la base
sera prêt je vous ferai un petit studio
tout de suite à un instant t donc ce
bien activités versus subjectivité et
tes goûts personnels et par rapport à
avant des choses pour le client à versus
pourquoi comment à quoi ça sert et c'est
vais bosser au plat arrête de vibrer
tour je vous montrerai un peu ici parce
côté subjectif c'est aussi une valeur
pour essayer de voir ce qu'il est
ton vécu c'est une chose maintenant pour
subjectivité on rompt peut-on faire
ma communauté au moins ça marche pas
s'il te plaît les gens aiment ça passe
que ce lieu est super cool je les adore
un sujet qui est extrêmement intéressant
qui est extrêmement forte il faut pas
objectif pour essayer de comprendre ce
tout ce qui va être sponsorisé doit
confiance son objectif suis-je subjectif
autant peut-on de faire confiance
cracher dessus il faut pas en avoir peur
vite mais c'est bon j'ai un train dans
j'espère que ça vous aura intéressé je
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
et ça me permettra de vous emmener un
qui fait partie du domaine de l'objectif
intéressant parce que quand on commence
faire partie d'un côté complètement
parce que quand on est comme ça en
peut-on de faire confiance pourquoi
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et
une deux heures donc deux heures je
est ce que mes avis mes conseils sont
à prendre une parole comme ça sur
résille oui mais je vais totalement
puis si vous avez des questions liées à
peu plus dans l'histoire en essayant de
parce que ton avis est ce qu'il est mais
donc de l'objectivité est ce qui fait
subjectif on n'est pas totalement sorti
objectif je vous présente un produit on
rentre chez moi je suis chez moi sic
youtube en tout cas comme ça comme moi
raconter un peu les choses différemment
mais là je suis à paris je rentre à
partie du domaine de la subjectivité
pertinents alors ça c'est à vous de me
fait je suis pas totalement subjectif
ce sujet la nouvelle est marquée en
tu bosses aussi avec des marques mais
regarde les specs par exemple je les
clermont vous vous en fichez mais je dis
qui ai commencé il ya quelques années je
de vous emmener davantage on voit
donc il faut le savoir mais il ya cette
aussi des partenariats aussi des marques
le dire ça c'est vous qui serez mieux le
parce qu'on a tous une part qui va être
quand même ce qui est super important
commentaire j'ai regardé jeu nécessite
ne viens pas d'une école de journalisme
regardais une certaines fonctionnalités
qui me plaît dans ce cadre là peut-on
l'espagne il ya plein de choses qui vont
subjectivité qui est là qu'il ya
dire mais l'idée globale c'est d'essayer
sur un sujet même à titre personnel
c'est de garder vraiment ce focus et
il n'ya pas longtemps je suis parti avec
de tous vous répondre c'est un peu
je ne viens pas d'une rédaction je ne
faire confiance et là aussi c'est un
arriver j'ai envie de faire plein de
inconsciente et qui est extrêmement
objective elliott un peu plus subjective
complexe mais je vais essayer de venir
samsung ils m'ont dit tiens ce que vous
trucs j'ai envie de raconter un peu et
sujet qui va falloir dire pondérée par
cette ligne-là savez c'est un peu l'idée
de comprendre en pl j'avais mis un
importante je me rappelle quand je
quand même et vous répondre parce que
suis pas journaliste je suis simple
ça je vous avais déjà expliqué au mois
qu'est-ce qui fait partie du domaine de
avec taillefer l'urbex et que tu as
celle-ci ou si je veux qu'on passe y ait
ce que il ya plusieurs choses à voir là
faisais mes études il ya une prof qui
c'est un sujet qui est super important
éclairage s'il est pas sur moi ça marche
de septembre de faire évoluer le format
passionné qui découvrent qu'ils testent
dedans qu'est ce qui se passe quand je
l'objectivité ce qui fait partie du
testé le samsung galaxy s 22 ultra en
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
moins bien c'est mieux comme ça assure
confiance si je veux vous croyez en ce
ce n'est pas toujours évident il faut du
et qui en testant et en évoluant en test
vais bosser avec une marque quand je
interrogations suggestions et puis on
domaine de l'objectivité ça va être les
nous avait dit revoici des faits on
faire ça les basterds a demandé ça tombe
temps et voyez les choses se font petit
que je vous dis si vous voyez marqué
fais une spawn sont avec une marque
urbex dans des conditions de nuit de
à petit mais elles se font pas donc
de plus en plus et qui du coup
faits se dire les choses qui sont
vidéo réalisée en partenariat avec une
quand je fais un partenariat avec une
bien voilà n'écoute pas l'idée de global
avait établi des faits qui était je
acquièrent une expérience alors j'avais
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
marque eh bien vous avez d'un côté la
continue pour ensuite vous allez voir il
établis telles qu'elles sont lorsque je
marque je vous dis que cette vidéo
faible luminosité au coucher du soleil
c'est de se dire est ce que mes avis
crois des faits d'actualité sur génocide
déjà une certaine crainte certaine
j'espère que ça vous aurait intéressé
réalisée en partenariat avec c'est une
ya un truc qui arrive tout sympa qu'on
vais vous parler notamment d'un
expertise personnel que j'ai acquis dans
et tu fais sans aux photos et en vidéos
j'espère que j'aurai réussi à vous
marque ça c'est elle et vous avez de
vidéo sponsorisés ça veut dire qu'ils
sont justes est ce que mes avis sont
smartphone va prendre l'exemple d'un
va se marrer là on va partir on va faire
de tonquedec c'est un truc qui était qui
marquent une paye pour faire quelque
smartphone l'objectivité absolue va se
et tu la regarder et ça peut pas être
montrer la façon dont je bosse à
le temps en restant en découvrant en
était extrêmement compliqué et nous a
l'autre côté je me mette versus parce
des voyages un petit peut être qu'ils
chose et si je veux vous continuer à
plus objectif parce que j'y vais je
vraies est ce que mes avis sont
qu'on travaille ensemble et vous avez de
expliciter les choses à expliciter les
recommencent à arriver un peu on va
faire sur les specs la fiche technique
dit vous allez bosser et vous allez nous
m'intéressant à titre perso et c'est
regarder ce contenu et que vous me
l'autre côté c'est un échange vous savez
véridiques est-ce qu'il faut les écouter
prends des photos je fais des vidéos
voyager pourra peut-être faire d'autres
croyez bien je dois être droit dans mes
si je met en face de smartphones et bien
choses qui peuvent être à venir analyse
écrire un article qui va être objectif
pour ça que je suis allé d'ailleurs
commencé à vous par les textes sur
pays on va faire notre pays on va aller
ensuite gelé des roches et je vous dise
ce qu'il faut me faire confiance ou a
vous devez être objectif et l'idée c'est
où je suis moi donc on va marquer greu
et j'espère que ça vous aura permis de
bottes et je dois être objectif et c'est
il y en a qui va voir un processeur plus
youtube mais plus j'en fais plus
venir comprendre j'ai vraiment hâte de
voir des trucs je vais essayer de vous
à nash ça marche pas c'est binaire c'est
comme ça on saura de qui on parle donc
contrario est-ce qu'il faut que ça paie
un exercice de tous les jours et c'est
performant lot qui aura un processeur
rentrer un peu plus dans l'analyse pour
de relater les faits sans aucune prise
embarquer avec moi je vais vous
découvre plus j'apprends plus je parle à
compliqué je le sais et c'est ce qui
c'est la question du jour et omar wade
moins performant ça va être des photos
ici on a deux personnes qu'est ce que
essayer de comprendre ce qui fait partie
embarquer on va partir ensemble et ça
zéro ou c1 je peux pas dire autre chose
de parti alors bien évidemment conserver
fait la différence tout la différence un
du domaine de l'objectif du vide partie
des personnes qui travaillent dans le
sens la question ici c'est la question
veut la marque elle la marque pas ce
quoique quand il ya une grosse partie de
d'ailleurs entre quelqu'un comme moi
du domaine du subjectif qui fait partie
c'est cool allez vous embrasse prenez
donc ça fonctionne ça fonctionne pas et
même métier que moi que ce soit des
qu'elle veut faire c'est avoir de la
qu'il veut bosser comme journaliste mais
subjectivité sur les photos mais on va
génocide il ya les méchants et les
soin de vous et vos proches
du domaine du conscience il faut aussi
je vous les affiches et après vous vous
visibilité sur ses produits et l'idée
qui ne serait pas journaliste parce que
journalistes ou que ce soit des des
gentils mais en fait là on dit pas ça
partie du domaine de l'inconscient a pas
voir le rendu si les meilleurs par
appropriez vous avez les commentaires
j'ai cette notion de partenariat avec
non il n'ya pas de méchants il n'y a pas
c'est de vendre des produits donc c'est
faire de la psycho ici c'est pas le but
contre sur un ultra grand-angle est ce
créateurs contenu que ce soit des
de gentils vous devez juste relater les
donc ça c'est totalement objectif mais
tout en sachant qu'il fallait regarder
qu'ils les déformant est ce qu'il n'est
des marques n'est pour autant et j'en
de générer de l'argent c'est son but
faits les c'est l'affect de côté les
pas déformant à skill-capped bien la
sur des tests produits il est évident
cette notion de partenariat je perds mon
suis convaincu on peut rester droit dans
marques que ce soit des agences
elle veut vous vendre et elle veut vous
lumière est ce qu'il ya un bon piqué
j'apprends je découvre j'en apprends
ses bottes en bossant comme ça donc à la
que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
vendre comment et bien elle fait appel à
bouche nobilo avec les marques qui est
sept côté un peu trop subjectif de côté
bref il ya plein de sujets qui sont
question suis-je objectif papa dans ces
davantage tous les jours et ça me permet
d'aller parler avec une marque sur un
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui des créateurs
extrêmement important qui est un sujet
extrêmement factuel sur lequel on ne
contenus notamment dans leurs plans
de renforcer un point qui est
essayez d'être totalement objectif vous
test produit parce qu'un côté qui va
très fort alors il chez moi il ya des
parties de façon un peu global suis-je
médias des créateurs contenus qui vont
extrêmement important et qui ici est
peut qu'être objectifs sinon on les
être beaucoup plus subjective donc ça
partenariats avec des marques mais c'est
objectif oui suis-je subjectif
permettre de mettre en avant des
relater les faits on était tous nombreux
pas la majorité voilà et j'espère que
mauvaises foi donc ici clairement sur
primordial c'est ce qu'on va appeler la
c'est quelque chose qui doit faire
partie de la ligne édito et ça ça doit
totalement également et d'ailleurs c'est
tout ce qui va être présentation de
produits pour générer des ventes faire
on a tous bossé là dessus et en fait on
produits sur tous ces partis là sur les
une fois de plus ces sujets c'est
compétence d'ailleurs c'est parce qu'on
intéressant
de business pour exister enfin bref ont
se rend compte que eh bien on a pris
faire partie et bien de présentation de
specs sur les fesses et une objectivité
vraiment le truc qui est vraiment
intéressante parce qu'elle est ce que
pris un peu l'histoire moi pourquoi est
va appeler ça s'appelle comme ça donc il
important chez moi c'est d'ailleurs je
absolue et entière maintenant le
vous auriez envie de suivre un mec qui
ce que ce sera avec des marques alors
spectre de choses très factuelle donc
ya plusieurs sujets ici suis-je objectif
bien évidemment c'est un peu la même
pense à tous les gens qui font ces
est totalement objectif totalement tout
je ne crois pas qu'il y en ait un seul
deuxième sujet ça va être un processus
diables à cenon le ferai pas je pense et
voilà un peu l'idée et voilà la façon de
idée que les marques c'est de pouvoir
qui va être plus inconscient si je dois
suis subjectif et suis-je compétents et
qui était objectif il ya toujours une
le temps c'est à dire que tu vas pas
financer ma chaîne de pouvoir avoir un
c'est la passion celle en vie ces voix
bosser
avoir d'avis tranché il peut y avoir un
choisir entre deux smartphones à spec
partie émotionnelle qui a été apportée
si vous savez il ya un truc qui est
je suppose que si vous êtes aujourd'hui
truc que moi j'aime pas que vous vous
salaire de pouvoir acheter du matériel
là mais il faut beau renée tout ça il
équivalente qu'est ce qui va venir me
même si on essayait de la minimiser même
important c'est que marjah n'est parfait
quelques 520 mille et quelques à me
allez adorer a contrario un truc que
permettre de départager tout ça il ya
de pouvoir avoir un local bref d'avoir
si on essaie de la cacher de la mettre
moi c'est un job que je fais depuis
faut mettre des bornes on peut aimer un
j'adore et que vous vous n'allez pas
plusieurs choses et c'est là où la
suivre sur youtube et puis 92 me
les conditions de travail qui nous
au fond nous elle ressortait d'une
truc mais si on veut le faire on veut le
aimer c'est ça qui fait la richesse
combien de temps allez j'ai commencé ma
partie de la subjectivité extrêmement
permettent de faire ce job là donc ça
après je développe mais j'explique
manière ou d'une autre mais c'est ça qui
faire bien et on veut s'inscrire dans la
lesquels je crois sur tictoc on s'en
importante c'est à dire que ça va
c'est aussi quelque part pour gagner des
pourquoi donc ça vous permet de vous y
est super compliqué alors bien
chaîne fin 2016 a parlé de teck et à
durée il faut donner un cadre et le
retrouver onze ans maintient par rapport
évidemment mais je vous parle pas de
englober plein de choses dont j'ai même
fout du nombre c'est que vous estimez en
euros ah oui je suis payé donc on va pas
à mes goûts est ce que ça marche est ce
génocide ici on parle pas de toutes les
pas moins nécessairement conscience
cadre il est là et pour moi le cadre
partie si vous êtes inscrit en tout cas
faire comme ce pays est vraiment à fond
se mentir j'ai pas vous dire non non je
que ça marche pas est-ce que c'est
problématiques là qui sont extrêmement
c'est à dire tiens je vais préférer ce
pertinent est ce que ça ne l'est pas
lourdes et graves ici on parle de teck
à mach ai dit si vous nous suivez
vous souhaite une marque elle ne paye
c'est travailler de cette manière là et
sérieux et focus depuis début janvier
donc je suis subjective et une part de
régulièrement même sans être inscrit
smartphone parce que il fait penser à
c'est par pure philanthropie non c'est
que tech et c'est un sujet qui est
d'ailleurs si vous n'êtes pas inscrit
subjectivité qui lui permet d'avoir mon
2018 donc c'est très récent et en ce
quelque chose quand on dit il fait
faire évoluer les choses pour que vous
beaucoup plus légère et qui a un sujet
vous invite à le faire vous allez petit
effectivement pour gagner ma vie mais et
individualité et ma force personnelle et
penser à quelque chose c'est un
qui est d'ailleurs je vois yeux parce
bouton rouge vous cliquez dessus et vous
puissiez toujours être plus nombreux
c'est super important il faut venir le
processus à un concert de choses qu'on a
que souvent quand on va parler de take
sens il ya des choses que j'ai appris il
plus nombreuses et en sachant que
actionnez la cloche pour authentifier
on va parler soit d'innovation va parler
relativiser pourquoi est-ce que je viens
intériorisé qui ressorte quand on voit
ya des choses que je fais bien les
lorsque vous arrivez sur la chaîne et
c'est probablement pour ça que vous êtes
qu'une prochaine vidéo arriver dès qu
choses que je fais moins bien je suis
bosser avec certaines marques et que
d'évolution dans le monde on va parler
que vous allez regarder une vidéo
là aujourd'hui parce que cette part
une prochaine vidéo arrivera plus pareil
qu'elle soit sponsorise ou qu'elles
passé par plein d'étapes différentes et
subjective qui est forte elle doit être
jean refuse beaucoup je refuse beaucoup
subjectif on l'a tous dans la vie de
de nouveaux produits on va parler de
soient pas sponsorisés
français que par vous connaissez un peu
juste à nous être justifiée elle doit
c'est ça qui est génial c'est ce chemin
tous les jours sur le côté hyper
choses qu'on a envie d'acheter ou pas on
plus que ce que j'accepte et bien c'est
l'histoire donc on peut dire que s'il ya
être clair mais j'ai mes goûts comme
qui me permet d'évoluer et d'expliquer
subjectif tiens je vois ça je préfère
va découvrir donc c'est un sujet qui est
du monde s'y est de plus en plus de
google est en train de parler en anglais
tout simplement pourquoi et bien parce
vous vous avez vos goûts on n'aime pas
donc je sais pas pourquoi mais c'est ça
gay c'est un sujet qui est joyeux et
monde qui vient de suivre c'est que on
les choses et dans des choses
tous la même chose heureusement qu'on
le je sais pas pourquoi d'incessants
que j'aime leurs produits sont des
pas si vous avez entendu ces brèves et
c'est pas un sujet qui appelle à la
me fait confiance on m'accorde du crédit
d'apprendre que ce soit sur cette
fait ses côtés extrêmement subjectif et
serait vachement triste et quand j'aime
tristesse donc on peut laisser plus part
marques avec qui tu bosses et que j'aime
qu est que on vient quelque part
quelque chose je vous explique pourquoi
gestion entreprise que c'est une gestion
bien quand j'écris sont à table chez les
ça on l'a tous quelle que soit la
à sa partie subjective je pense que
si on veut avancer il faut avoir son
reconnaître une certaine compétence pour
et je vous emmène là dedans et ça c'est
gunners ça c'est super important
d'entreprise que ce soit sur les
personne qu'on est quelle que soit notre
c'est un sujet qui est super important
clair et c'est le sujet du jour peut-on
pourquoi tout ça permet de garder une
focus et vous savez moi dans mon job il
vous guider dans le choix de vos
foi quelle que soit notre job on a une
de savoir optimiser savoir-faire de la
partenariats avec les maths donc tout ça
faire confiance j'espère creuse à la fin
j'aime beaucoup c'est à dire que on est
partie subjective il faut pas laisser la
cohérence et ça me permets moi de vous
smartphones où vous expliquer des choses
je l'apprends sur le tas et ça me permet
mélangé en fait quand on est dans la
partie subjective prendre le pas sur la
de cette vidéo vous dirais ok on peut
recommander de choses que j'aime alors
tête qu'on est mélangé où on allait le
liées à la fois c'est ce qui semble être
partie subjective une réforme alors ok
rien tout est super intéressant lorsque
faire confiance à ce n'est qu' on peut
d'évoluer alors bien évidemment il ya
créateur de contenus influenceurs quatre
le cas maintenant le sujet de
partie objective et sur les faits donc
le croire on peut le suivre et que ça
je bosse avec des marques j'essaye
il faut chercher à réfléchir et ça ça te
aussi eu quelques ratés je pense sur
ans qu'on puisse pas servir ça et on
vous aura pas convaincu parce que si
d'aller toujours sur des vidéos qui vont
travaille en parallèle avec des
rappelle à quoi ça fait appel aux
certains partenariats avec des marques
journalistes et sur sa super intéressant
vous êtes là et si vous regardez
compétences et ça fait appel aussi autre
où il a fallu aussi moi réussir à
être plus des vidéos de présentation ou
peut-être vous convaincu ou peut-être
parce que c'est très riche
chose qui va choix important c'est à la
pour montrer un truc extrêmement factuel
avez-vous des interrogations sur le
d'enseignements devoir d'écouter et de
apprendre et apprendre map avant disons
notion de jugement et du jugement
sujet c'est un sujet qui est extrêmement
donc venir travailler sur le domaine de
important à l'heure après que chacun
ok peut-être qu'il ya une partie qui est
regarder comment boss le journaliste et
éclairé pourquoi est-ce que je pense ce
travaille différemment attention il y en
un peu un peu pas totalement objectif
j'apprends énormément à côté d'eux et ça
a qui fonctionneront différemment juge
l'objectif donc lorsque je vais venir
matin je pense à oui mais est-ce que si
pas chacun sait ce qu'il veut ça les
je pense ça ça dessert pas ça il faut
me permet vraiment de se dire ok ils
bosser avec une marque pour venir gagner
peut-être une part un peu trop
regarde voilà mais ça c'est ma façon de
subjective mais ça c'est aussi des
font ça comme ça où la tension et je les
toujours remettre en question un peu le
de l'argent je focus à 100% sur
faire c'est ma façon de bosser c'est ma
vois toujours en train de skull c'est
erreurs qu'on fait quand on apprend et
côté extrêmement subjective mais ce côté
façon de voir les choses et bon jeu ça
super j'imagine que j'ai pas le copage
quand on évolue dans ce diable alors
l'objectivité et sur les faits pour
subjectif il existe et continuera à
monestir gardent tout de suite à
aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas mais ç'a
ne changera pas c'est comme ça voilà
beaucoup avouent ils sont toujours en
exister et je pense que c'est même
justement ne pas tomber ne pas tomber
eu probablement été le cas au
d'ailleurs une des forces qui fait que
train de dire d'avoir truc un peu genre
commencement et lors de l'évolution est
j'espère avoir fait le tour de la
la grosse de retour hier dit oui mais
neutre est tombé dans les billets du
vous avez peut-être me suivre si vous
sur le chemin mais ce qui est sûr et
question j'espère que ce sujet vous
allez me suivre si vous cliquez sur le
subjectif parce qu'il est évident que
certain c'est que l'importance et
aurez intéressé moi je trouve super
bouton rouge et si vous êtes sonner la
intéressant et super passionnant et
cloche ce que je vous mais d'affaires
lorsqu'une marne va venir payer même
l'évolution et si on veut progresser si
d'ailleurs j'en profite petit aparté
on veut aller plus loin si on veut
vous l'avez remarqué on a les plans
compte regardez la confiance et être
[Musique]